in a 2019 presidential debate tulsi
gabbard called out kamala and her record
on stage
senator harris says she's proud of her
record as a prosecutor and that she'll
be a prosecutor president but i'm deeply
concerned about this record
there are too many examples to cite but
she put over 1500 people in jail for
marijuana violations and then laughed
about it when she was asked if she ever
smoked marijuana
she blocked evidence
she blocked evidence that would have
freed an innocent man from death row
until the courts forced her to do so she
kept people in prison beyond their
sentences to use them as cheap labor for
the state of california and she fought
to keep cash bail system in place that
impacts poor people in the worst kind of
way oh camilleris did not like that
tulsi gabbard is a former presidential
candidate and congresswoman and she
joins us now tulsi great to see you to
add to that inconsistency we now have
kamla today condemning russia how do we
make sense of the vice president
that that's a great question will
another another note of hypocrisy coming
from kamal harris this administration is
as you mentioned how during her
illustrious record as attorney general
in california you gave some of those
examples she kept prisoners in prison
longer than their sentences to use them
as free slave labor yet at the same time
these very same people are condemning
other countries for doing the exact same
thing it doesn't make any sense the
thing that struck me when i saw kamala
harris's tweet and her statement
expressing this outrage
about brittany griner first of all let
me say
i don't think anybody anywhere in the
world world should be imprisoned for
marijuana possession period full stop
when you look at kamal harris's
statement on twitter she's expressing
this outrage about brittany griner my
question for her and the biden
administration is where is your outrage
for your fellow americans who are
sitting in prison today here in the
united states of america because of
minor marijuana violations how come you
are not fighting as hard for them
to be returned home and reunited with
their families as you are for brittany
griner and to me the message to the
american people through their actions
is loud and clear is that if you are
rich and powerful or famous then you
will get special treatment from this
administration if you are not now we
don't care about you and we're going to
let you sit there and rot in jail
chelsea do you think that's what it is
it's simply
sheer unadulterated elitism or is it a
reflection of kamala harris's emptiness
that she is simply willing to play to
wherever the current
climate stream river is flowing when it
was flowing in california to prosecute
marijuana she was happy to ride that
stream and when it's unpopular she's
happy to go on a morning show and
pretend that she listened to tupac
shakur years before he ever came out and
laugh along to the idea that she smoked
marijuana it seems she's an empty vessel
yeah well well i think it's both and and
as as you pointed out the evidence
really is in her record uh not only on
this this issue but i know there are a
lot of examples on other issues where
unfortunately like too many politicians
it seems like she puts her finger to the
wind and decides what things she's
supposed to be angry about on any given
day and then if it becomes politically
inconvenient or damaging then she'll
switch the other way we saw this i know
healthcare was one issue during the
presidential campaign on monday tuesday
wednesday and thursday she gave almost
opposing answers on that issue leaving
even the mainstream media like i know
the new york times saying what do you
actually where do you stand on on health
care
and and so you know i think it's
unfortunate it's unfortunate that we
have a vice president united states who
doesn't appear to stand for anything
other than herself oh you make a great
point though
you know condemning russia for something
that the vice president has very little
control while leaving americans to
suffer under the punishment of those
very similar laws right here in america
where you do have
control tulsi gabbard you called her out
then thank you for calling her out again
tonight
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight